bonjour bienvenue on ouvre l'enquête ce
matin quel est donc ce mystérieux ballon
qui survole les États-Unis les
Américains sont sur deux c'est de
l'espionnage chinois alors pourquoi
n'interviennent-ils pas alors qu'il
survolerait des zones militaires
sensibles cette année rien comprendre
Nicolas Barotte bonjour bonjour vous
allez nous éclairer on va essayer ouais
nous donner des réponses Nicolas
spécialiste des questions de défense au
service international du Figaro bon
racontez-moi cette histoire cette
histoire d'abord que se passe-t-il dans
le ciel américain donc les Américains le
Pentagone a fait une déclaration donc
hier pour pour préciser qu'ils avaient
identifié donc un ballon de surveillance
chinois
catégoriques sur la provenance du ballon
qui donc surveille le territoire
américain OK et donc au dessus du
Montana
où il y a des sites sensibles de l'armée
américaine qu'ils ont signalé
signalement stratégique dans un
avertissement pour dire chinois on vous
a vu d'accord et aussi prévenir aussi
l'audience américaine et internationale
pour dire voilà ce qui se passe en
pratique des Chinois on a les images de
ce ballon alors c'est assez lointain
vous le voyez ça ressemble presque à la
lune oui comme ça
c'est invisible depuis le soir ça c'est
une attitude qui n'est pas confirmé par
les par les Américains mais ça ce ne
sont pas des images prises avec un
smartphone
normalement a priori on n'a pas de
confirmation sur l'altitude mais c'est
au-delà de de 20 km donc c'est très très
haut donc à l'oeil nu on ne peut pas le
voir
l'armée américaine a envoyé des avions
pour étudier observer donc c'est sans
doute une image d'avion du sol il y a
c'est peu probable sauve avec des
instruments bien sûr de de l'observation
plus développé mais à l’œil nu ça ne se
ça se voit pas comment l'information est
devenu public j'imaginais que
sur ces questions d'espionnage de
sécurité les autorités essayer d'être le
plus discrète secrète possible pourquoi
elle communique puisque preuve en est
vous me le dites depuis le sol on peut
pas le voir à l'oeil nu donc là il
communique sur cette question sont parce
que le Pentagone a voulu dire au chinois
nous avons vu ah oui simplement ça peut
être ça peut être ça ou alors la crainte
du d'une fuite et que la communication
échappe d'autorité américaine bon est-ce
que vous pouvez me donner sa taille à ce
ballon non on n'a pas il est assez gros
suffisamment gros pour que l'armée
américaine décide de ne pas l'abattre
parce qu'il va la crainte que des débris
retombent sur le sur le territoire et
puis c'est endommager des habitations
des infrastructures que ça j'ai encore
donc c'est assez volumineux malgré tout
c'est un satellite donc d'observation
donc
de charge
utile avec des capteurs et donc on n'a
pas sa taille mais c'est saute très
conséquent et par ailleurs le ballon
pour pouvoir voler et être stationnaire
doit être aussi assez volumineux donc
l'objet
j'ai entendu que CNN c'est très
américain disait que il faisait la
taille de 3 bus c'est possible c'est
possible après c'est parce que le ballon
le ballon trois bus la charge utile le
matériel est forcément plus petit parce
que évidemment malgré tout il y a des
contraintes d'emports
quelle est la zone que surveille ce
ballon il est où exactement donc il
serait au dessus du Montana d'accord on
voit ici sur cette carte c'est un
endroit où notamment les silos de
domicile nucléaires américains ce qu'il
faut noter surtout ce qui a alerté les
Américains c'est que contrairement à
d'autres épisodes de surveillance par
des ballons qui ont déjà été observé
auparavant c'est que celui-ci a une
caractéristique c'est une avantage
stationnaire d'accord c'est une des
grandes difficultés de ce type d'objet
c'est pas qu'il dérivent au gré du des
vivants
pour observer donc ça veut dire qu'il
est piloté il n'est pas livré à lui-même
au milieu du de l'espace et à se balader
au gré du vent alors pas s'il est piloté
ou s'il est contrôlé à peu près tout le
monde sait pas trop comment ça
fonctionne précisément mais
effectivement il est il reste il
persiste sur la zone donc ce qui montre
que il a un intérêt spécifique à
observer cette zone là du territoire
américain et ça montre aussi qu'il est
chinois ont réussi à maîtriser ou
comment ça maîtriser cette technique du
vol en très haute altitude avec une
persistance avec une capacité
stationnaire et ça est compliqué parce
que les ballons précédemment pouvaient
traverser le territoire et donc certes
il y avait du l'espionnage mais pas en
continu là c'est que c'est persistant il
vient du nord il est passé par le Canada
ce ballon c'est ce que on peut on peut
lire c'est effectivement
on peut pas faire mieux
technologiquement aujourd'hui c'est
quand même très visible on peut pas
faire j'imaginer les drones des je sais
pas des avions un peu secrets non ça
c'est très visible non mais justement
c'est c'est assez intéressant comme
technique parce que un satellite qui
peut aussi faire de la surveillance bon
c'est coûteux et c'est cher envoyer dans
l'espace et par ailleurs avec les
orbites ce n'est pas en permanence au
dessus au dessus du sol des
drones ou des avions furtifs c'est pour
ça qu'il est pénètre le territoire
l'espace n'a rien américain d'accord
donc là ce sera une agression si c'est
pas autorisé là cet objet en fait il
vole dans un endroit de très haute
altitude entre entre 20 km et qui n'est
pas vraiment réglementé en réalité c'est
pas vraiment l'espace aérien américain
et par ailleurs l'avantage c'est que
c'est assez
peu coûteux en réalité c'est un ballon
oui donc à fabriquer c'est pas c'est
compliqué mais c'est pas très 2 c'est il
y a beaucoup de technologies derrière
mais par rapport à des drones de très
très rotels par rapport à des ateliers
c'est c'est beaucoup moins cher donc
c'est un intérêt et c'est pour ça que
beaucoup d'armées notamment les
Américains mais aussi les Français ça
intéresse à des types technologies on va
parler de cette technologie mais là on
parle d'espionnage géographique du
certaine manière puisqu'ils survole vous
l'avez dit le Montana ou il y aurait des
stocks de missiles c'est ça américain
pour résumer ce qui peut recuire
d'autres informations tout dépend avec
quel type de capteur il est équipé alors
de quel type de capteur
on ne sait pas parce que pour le coup on
n'a pas pas d'éléments c'est pas si les
Américains eux-mêmes le savent ce que
les Américains disent c'est que il n'y a
pas de plus-value sans doute avec ce
type de matériel en termes de
renseignement par rapport à mon
satellite qui ferait de l'observation
d'image mais bon on peut aussi imaginer
déjà que ce soit un test pour les chats
pour pour voir ce qu'ils peuvent
emporter faire
un test de matériel et à terme on peut
avoir des éléments de capteur d'image
fixes alors qu'on a définitivement le
satellite il passe il repasse mais il
est pas en permanence d'accord avoir des
capteurs aussi électromagnétiques ah oui
c'est ça pour capter les ondes et des
communications et ce sont de plus facile
avec avec un ballon plus proche du sol
avec un satellite qui est non plus
éloigné même s'il est technologies sont
très compliquées à maîtriser
donc voilà c'est le des capteur c'est
l'image et électromagnétique
principalement
électromagnétique trafiquer radio trafic
de téléphonie c'est tout ce qui est tout
ce qui est de tous ces tout ce qui est
communication ça peut être capté
potentiellement même si on sait pas
quelle est la performance des éléments
qui sont emmenés par ce ballon c'est une
technologie ancienne c'est ces ballons
gélules que ça avait été adopté sa
datait de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
alors oui oui non c'est cuvettes le
principe du dirigeable c'est c'est assez
ancien c'est cette idée de d'avoir un
ballon tout ça maintenant ça avait été
un peu abandonné parce que en termes de
rapport coût intérêt efficacité c'était
moins intéressant que de l'aviation que
des drones que des satellites parce que
aussi le la difficulté dans cet endroit
là c'est de pouvoir rester en permanence
si c'est pour traverser un avion ça peut
un peu le faire ou un satellite mais
comment est-ce qu'on a un ballon qui
soit inaccessible justement en défense
entière qui soit persistant au-dessus au
dessus du sol ça demande de la maîtrise
technologique notamment des de la dérive
qui n'est pas passable donc c'était
connu des armées depuis assez longtemps
d'accord mais c'est un peu
sous-exploiter c'était pas la priorité
et là aujourd'hui c'est ça qui
m'intéresse aujourd'hui c'est presque ce
qui se fait de mieux c'est la pointe de
la technologie pour espionner depuis
l'espace du désert en tout cas c'est un
nouveau domaine c'est un nouveau domaine
que les armées commencent à
investir à réfléchir en terme de
capacité de stratégie parce qu'on voit
bien que un oiseau très proche il y aura
une compétition dans cet endroit là et
donc il faut pouvoir y accéder et
intervenir et savoir ce que les autres
sont mesures de fer en termes
d'espionnage en termes de de guidage de
de survol aussi on peut imaginer toutes
sortes de d'éléments il y a les ballons
mais on peut aussi imaginer des sortes
d'avions qui pourraient voler dans cette
attitude pour aller transporter des
troupes très rapidement à l'autre bout
du globe voilà il y a un défi
technologique de maîtrise cet
environnement ce n'est plus les airs ce
n'est pas encore l'espace c'est une zone
intermédiaire qui peut être exploité
c'est la très haute altitude voilà c'est
le lieu en fait c'est l'endroit où vont
circuler à trop de vitesse les missiles
hypersoniques qui rebondit sur
l'atmosphère euh ça va être donc le lieu
où on envoie des des ballons de de
surveillance euh ça va être aussi un
lieu où on peut imaginer qu'on envoie un
jour des drôles de très très haute
altitude les les drones les plus
performants là ils mangent jusqu'à
18000 km d'accord prenez encore un petit
peu de kilomètres c'est ça
aux alentours de 20 à partir au-delà de
20 au-delà on serait que 10 les sources
américaines c'est plutôt autour de une
trentaine de kilomètres même si on n'a
pas de précision les pentagones n'a pas
n'a pas confirmé mais mais c'est l'idée
et donc cet endroit là il est
difficilement accessible pour des moyens
de parler pour des avions par exemple
et il y a un potentiel d'exploitation
assez intéressant notamment pour
l'aspect coufon parce qu'on a pas envoyé
un satellite donc on a pas les lanceurs
les fusées et toute la pratique ça c'est
l'un des avantages de ces ballons j'en
lis d'autres c'est quasiment un
détectable c'est vrai
pas de signature thermique par exemple
ça c'est important mais là si vous
voulez se dire c'est que aujourd'hui les
armées ont des systèmes de détection de
l'espace aérien des systèmes aussi de
suivi c'était en orbite mais ils ont pas
développé de moyens de radar de capacité
d'observation pour cette très haute
altitude donc ils sont un peu dépourvu
de capacité pour repérer identifier
suivre donc là encore il faudra
développer des éléments qui peuvent
détecter ces objets le problème c'est
qu'effectivement il y a pas de signaux
thermiques dont c'est pas facile à
observer
ces deux de savoir d'où il a été lancé
un satellite on sait on connaît les
différentes bases spatiales sur sur le
sol ce type de ballon peut être envoyé
en l'air de n'importe où n'importe quel
il a une très grande autonomie c'est ce
que j'ai vu puisque de fait il ne
consomme rien ou presque absolument
parce qu'il donc il se laisse dériver et
arriver à sa zone cible après en place
des moyens pour rester stationnaire un
certain temps et après oui ce qui est
intéressant c'est que il survole cette
zone ici le Montana il viendrait du
Canada mais lorsqu'on voit où est la
Chine on se dit que s'il a été lancé
depuis la Chine il en fait du chemin ce
ballon c'est ça qui est impressionnant
on sait pas quand les Américains l'ont
détecté ils disent depuis quelques jours
donc effectivement très vague
peut-être des zones si on va le
Pacifique ou on peut pas avoir des
moyens de surveillance en permanence et
qui scrute le ciel au-dessus de
l'ocympathique constamment ça ça
demanderait beaucoup de moyens
technologiques pour pour peu de
résultats donc effectivement c'est pas
du tout observé les Américains ont
observé donc ce ballon ils sont sûrs à
100% que c'est un un ballon chinois pour
de l'espionnage déjà ils ont envoyé des
avions pour ça pour faire de la
reconnaissance de l'observation ce
qu'ils en sont absolument certains
est-ce qu'on peut les croire de toute
façon c'est une source officielle mais
disent et qui t'en sont sûrs alors ils
ont pas donné de preuves d'éléments
concrets quand ils peuvent savoir ce
qu'ils ont vu la trajectoire du ballon
depuis son envol etc ou bien ils ont vu
des éléments
typiques dans la structure du ballon il
correspond à d'autres matériels du même
type c'est à dire que les agents qui se
rapprocher par exemple ou par télescope
ils peuvent voir précisément parce que
là l'image est de caractère chinois
peut-être par exemple il faut imaginer
que ce genre de choses mais la limace
qu'on voit effectivement c'est assez
flouf il faut bien se dire que avec des
optiques de haute précision ou du
satellite on peut voir très précisément
donc bien sûr les autres américaines ont
des images précises de l'objet et donc
ils peuvent le caractériser mais alors
s'il s'agit d'un ballon chinois pourquoi
les Américains ne l'abatt-il pas on le
sait il répète souvent par exemple en
cas de menaces terroristes si un avion
ne répond plus par exemple ils sont
prêts à l'abattre là il a un risque pour
les populations au-dessus du Montana
franchement oui mais quel est le risque
pour les populations si on Abasse ballon
il y a toujours un risque qu'il y a
quand même des des villes donc il y a
une potentiel pour que des débris tombe
sur le sol par ailleurs quel est le
danger de ce ballon sauf qu'il y a une
étude qui a été menée par les Américains
et ils sont que les chinois ne sont pas
assez fous pour remettre une menace
visible au dessus de son américain donc
la néglise qui a été faite c'est que ce
ballon n'est pas une menace pour le
territoire américain et que par ailleurs
le renseignement qu'il peut collecter
n'est pas supérieur à ce que les chiens
peuvent déjà connectés avec leur
satellite alors la menace elle est
visible et les nouvelles mais elle n'est
pas plus grande que d'autres capacités
donc vous me dites les Américains
considèrent qu'avec leur satellites les
Chinois récup plus de données et
d'informations qu'avec ce ballon
pourquoi les Chinois font ça est-ce que
les chinois se sont manqués tout
simplement est-ce que ce ballon n'a rien
à faire là alors c'est peu probable
quand même ils puissent qui reste
stationnaire c'est que c'est pas manqué
et comme on l'a dit c'est peut-être
aussi un test c'est un domaine nouveau
pour les armées donc il faut il faut
tester les capacités de tester ce qu'on
peut faire et peut-être que tout
simplement les Chinois regardent ce
qu'ils peuvent faire obtenir réaliser
avec ce type d'engin et ils sont en ce
moment à Pékin en train de comparer
l'intérêt du ballon avec ce qu'ils ont
en renseignement du même type
satellitaire après ce qu'il faut bien se
dire c'est que on en a un mais on peut
imaginer dans quelques années une
décennie qui en est beaucoup et donc à
un moment donné comment est-ce que on
fait pour se défendre contre beaucoup de
ballons qui pourraient survoler les
territoires américains ou européens si
c'est systématisé si la capacité
d'emport de matériel augmente et que
donc les capteurs sont très performants
voilà
les Chinois testent des choses sans
doute regarde ce sont les possibilités
et de fait les puissances occidentales
et États-Unis en premier ligne
évidemment regarde comment s'en prémunir
et comment comment contrer ce type de
d'action et donc dévoiler le dévoiler ce
comportement c'est aussi une réponse
Pékin appelle à ne pas monter les choses
en épingle ils n'ont pas démenti les
Chinois à l'heure actuelle
la déclaration précise de la parole du
ministère de faire étrangère chinois
elle dit
l'espace Andy la Chine n'a pas
l'intention de violer l'espace aérien
américain bon bah objectivement c'est ce
qui est le cas
d'espace aérien américain oui parce
qu'il est au-dessus d'une certaine
altitude est-ce que vous m'expliquez
dessus et donc tiens ça veut dire aussi
que les Américains n'ont peut-être pas
le droit de la battre
si le au-dessus de leur espace si parce
que pour le pour le coup c'est il
pourrait il pourrait considérer
international chacun doit poser le
problème c'est que c'est une zone où il
y a peu de réglementation aussi il y a
donc le droit qui s'applique ou contrôle
des espaces aériens nationaux ça c'est
clair il y a aussi des textes qui
existent pour l'espace exo atmosphérique
et
satellites mais cette très haute
altitude elle est peu réglementée et
donc c'est aussi un besoin pour les
étapes de commencer à réfléchir à la
régulation le contrôle de cet espace là
pour éviter que tout et n'importe quoi
il circule je lis ce que nous dit
Monsieur Thomas il Renise un vaisseau
extraterrestre oui peut-être c'est un
ovni
il nous dit aussi et c'est ce qu'on
expliquait les Chinois des satellites
pour quand on verrait-il un ballon c'est
une nouvelle technologie qui
est en face de test les capacités et
comme comme on l'a dit le satellite il
passe il repasse donc il y a pas d'image
en continu un ballon il peut rester
plusieurs
jours au même endroit alors ce ne serait
pas selon les américains selon le
Pentagone la première fois que ça arrive
sauf que cette fois se balance serait
resté plus longtemps dans l'espace
aérien américain ça veut dire que les
Chinois progressent là à ce moment-là
absolument c'est ça c'est c'était la
frontière technologique et c'est là où
beaucoup d'entreprises travaillent c'est
réussir à avoir une permanence il y a un
contrôle d'une guerre d'espionnage
importante entre la Chine et les
Américains on pense notamment à cette
éternelle serpent de mer autour de
Huawei par exemple la célèbre entreprise
chinoise qui s'implante en Amérique du
Nord c'est l'avenir cette
se renseignement permanent que vont
chercher essayer de chercher des
Américains les Chinois c'est la
stratégie des de la Chine donc il y a
une volonté de d'être une puissance
entre la première puissance mondiale au
milieu du siècle et pour y parvenir et
là un moyen particulier c'est
l'espionnage à grande échelle que ce
soit l'espionnage humain classique que
ce soit le cyberespional que ce soit ce
type de matériel pour acquérir des
technologies rattraper fait penser aux
Russes de la période de la guerre froide
ça avec ce KGB
omnipotent partout tout le temps c'est
ce que essaye de faire les Chinois c'est
un peu différent parce que guerre froide
il y a vraiment une opposition un
antagoniste entre les entre les deux
blocs d'accord là les chenilles font
aussi du commerce donc ils ont aussi
intérêt à ce qui est est-ce qu'on
conserve des liens commerciaux pour
diffuser leur propre produit leur
technologie donc ils sont un rapport de
force qui est moins confrontationnel si
on peut dire ça comme ça avec les
Américains mais ils ont effectivement
une ambition de puissance et comme ils
ont beaucoup de moyens ils investissent
dans les nouvelles technologies que ce
soit donc libère informatique quantique
mais là aussi on le voit dans ce domaine
spatial et
quelles peuvent être les conséquences
diplomatiques alors j'ai vu une
information je suis je pense que ce
serait presque passé une aperçu quoi que
mais Anthony blinken le secrétaire
d'État américain donc le ministre des
Affaires étrangères pour comparer à la
France étant déplacement en Chine
dimanche et lundi c'est une première
depuis 2018 comme par hasard les
Américains dévoilent cette information
alors qu'il le disent de même ça arrive
assez régulièrement
c'est parti du jeu du rapport de force à
la fois le fait que les Chinois on voit
ce ballon avant une visite diplomatique
c'est aussi une petite provocation un
test faites d'y répondre c'est
montrer qu'on a des capacités de réagir
des réponses de voir de toute façon la
relation diplomatique entre la Chine et
les États-Unis et les marquer par du
rapport de force bien sûr donc il faut
il faut montrer il faut montrer de la
puissance de la capacité et pas de
naïveté donc c'est parti du du théâtre
avant avant le déplacement du secrétaire
mission commence va se terminer cette
histoire est-ce que ce ballon va partir
va quitter le seul américain est-ce que
les États-Unis seront obligés de
l'abattre à un moment ou un autre
comment est-ce qu'on peut imaginer ce
qui va se passer maintenant alors il
peut probable que que le ballon puisse
rester éternellement
au dessus des tours américains
de fonctionnement mais ces ressources
vont s'épuiser et à un moment donné il
va devoir à nouveau dériver et sans que
les Chinois font récupérer ce qu'il
s'écrase américain ce qui serait un
avantage énorme pour les Américains
que ce soit plus étudier donc ce ballon
va reprendre son chemin à un moment
donné pour retourner vers son sa base
d'origine ou en tout cas un lieu où la
Chine pourra récupérer à la fois l'objet
et éventuellement une part des données
si toutes n'ont pas été transmises au
fur et à mesure à la Chine donc à un
moment donné ce ballon va s'éloigner qui
fait de l'humour visiblement ça inspire
nos internautes ils sont gonflés oui
c'est vrai et il nous dit aussi on l'a
expliqué le Montana c'est pas si peuplé
que ça je comprends pas trop pourquoi il
ne le neutralise pas vous inquiétez pas
on termine ce live mais vous l'avez en
replay vous remontez et Nicolas de vous
explique tout ça merci Nicolas merci de
nous avoir accompagné spécialiste des
questions de défense au service
international du Figaro d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour vous donner cette le
programme ce soir Sophia vous savez la
nouvelle astronaute française et
l'invité du figarolive de mon jour dans
la nouvelle émission libre à vous c'est
très intéressant pour rester évidemment
avec nous toute la journée parce qu'il y
a plein de choses on va parler de rugby
tout à l'heure avec Vincent roseron il y
aura point de vue à 18h vous ne raterez
rien merci de nous avoir suivi
excellente journée sur le figurant